July is minority mental health month
it's meant to stop the stigma and start
conversations about mental health in
minority communities where the topic
often gets overlooked Victoria Saha
spoke with officials about the
disparities sent has our story tonight
struggles with mental health can often
go on in silence and for minority
communities it's something that doesn't
get talked about often and as we start
to have this conversation each year in
July becomes more important to
um to create strategies to help people
understand the importance of mental
health especially in communities where
we recognize people deal with specific
disparities Lakeisha Oliver is a mental
health therapist for Solutions of change
she says she sees people in minority
communities live most of their lives
without ever asking for help which is
why minority mental health month in July
helps start the conversation we do find
that people come in in their 40s 50s and
60s even later on in life to talk about
things that they've never talked about
before according to the UMass Department
of Health and Human Services in 2020
suicide was the second leading cause of
death of Asian Americans and Pacific
Islanders ages 20 to 34. Oliver says up
to 40 percent of people don't ask for
help until four to five years after a
traumatic event we work in a way that
helps the client recognize what the
foundational need is because it may have
been so long that they don't even know
what that is but our goal is to make
sure that you're okay right now so that
we can start digging deep and finding
out what's causing you to feel the way
that you feel no matter how long it's
been taking the first step to reach out
for help and starting that conversation
is crucial Victoria Saha 8 news now
Solutions Solutions of change rather as
hosting a community event July 14th and
15th called healing to health we'll have
details on our website if you'd like to
attend